und ich kann bilder wie ich sie am
wochenende wieder gesehen habe von
partys die hier stattfinden nicht
verstehen ich kann nicht verstehen dass
es in dieser stadt restaurants gibt in
die ich reingehe der einzigen mit maske
binnen und wurde dann noch angeguckt
wird als wärst irgendwie vom anderen
mond wenn du eine maske trägt und ihr
dann noch gesagt wir brauchen sie hier
nicht tragen und soll ich doch brauche
ich nicht nur muss ich sogar nach den
regeln dieser stadt aber regeln müssen
dann auch durchgesetzt werden
das dient vor allem übrigens auch um all
diejenigen zu unterstützen die sich
jeden tag an regeln halten die große
mehrheit der berlinerinnen und berliner
wie die große mehrheit der bundesbürger
hält sich jeden tag zum schutz der
mitbürger an die aha regeln und dann all
die vorgaben und ich finde die haben es
dann auch verdient die die sich daran
halten dass da wo sich nicht dran
gehalten wird dann eben auch
entsprechend ist zu kontrollen und
gegebenenfalls sanktionen kommt ich
halte gar nichts davon dass wir ständig
über neue regeln und maßnahmen reden
ich wäre schon sehr froh wenn es gelänge
überall die bestehenden regeln
durchzusetzen und das durchsetzen dient
ja vor allem auch dazu denjenigen die
sich an die regeln jeden tag halten
jeden von uns passiert es mal im alltag
dass diese maske nervt eben von uns geht
es mal so dass er eigentlich gerne mal
wieder jemanden begrüßen würde und im
zweifel nicht gleich ein abstand wieder
denken würde
hinter jedem so aber die allermeisten
sagen diese regeln sind richtig weil sie
auch vergleichsweise milde sind im
vergleich zu dem was wir sonst so an
maßnahmen sehen und folgen sehen und sie
sagen sie leben sie aus überzeugung zwar
nicht nur für sich zuerst sondern um
andere ihre bürger mitbürgerinnen und
mitbürger ihre familien ihr umfeld zu
schützen
und gerade diese vielen haben es doch
verdient dass die wenigen aber in
manchen städten eben zu viele wenige die
sich nicht an regeln halten nicht an
regeln halten wollen die sagen ich bin
20 junge und unsterblich das reicht aber
eben nicht jeder 20 jährige
trifft auch mal ältere oder menschen mit
vorerkrankungen dass diejenigen dann
halt gesagt kriegen regeln gelten für
alle und das gilt insbesondere dann eben
auch wenn es um partys und
veranstaltungen geht wenn ich mir jeden
tag im lagebericht anschaue wo haben wir
infektionsherde
dann sind das alles bereiche für die es
schon regeln gibt es liegt nicht an zu
wenig regeln mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schau dich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren